die sendung tierärztin 24 7 wird ihnen
präsentiert von problemen mit der kraft
katzen allergene zu reduzieren
[Musik]
intensive kontrollen die jetzt im 2
florence
alex und immer noch vorne sind mit viele
rede auf die brüssler blieb stecken aber
schon bald merkt das zum alltag von
regier jetzt im tricks und
unvorhergesehen mit
[Musik]
stets ihr neuer die ärztin
in florence ihre dort funkt im
freiburgischen wilde westen geht
erwartet sie es um tricks
des sebastian ist eine leidenschaftliche
westen und hat fotobuch im internet cdu
kraft
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sie faszinieren immer ganz so lang
[Musik]
nur morgen von ihrem geburtstag auf
facebook gesehen dass sc buch kraft
jetzt trainiert
[Musik]
ich habe mir ist sie nur im internet was
google tut
[Musik]
besonders groß aber dem verhauten ses
wählt jeder und nicht wirklich zu
bedrohlich als impulsiv weiß blüht nicht
könnt potosi oder in ein anderes
aber ich sehe
ja sagt herzig da muss frau steht helmut
wanko
nervös und unbedacht aber aber glaubt
ihr challenge selbst wie also konkret
ihr habt so
wird ganz ruhig
wäre sofort merkt das konzept ist gut
das ist auch
so merkt sofort wenn die losgeht
ziemlich schnell merken wo blüht das
nicht kannte ist es extrem
nachgelassen
[Musik]
weil gott nimmt es sebastians los
dass ich spiele ja
nicht
werbe star bill gates aber wird es dir
nie so beweglich jetzt kompliziert ja
wenn es nur cool so werde die cdu
eigentlich züchtet
andere straßen ruhig stellt
elodie haben sebastian pini freundin
grund nummer sonne wie es unbedingt
nötig ist
schon beim kauf hat sich der sebastian
bete die kunden drum set florence
sohnes cebu ich ziemlich unberechenbar
in das
nicht kennt die verteidigte das heißt es
geht oft mit losen oder schluss mit
dabei und muss man sich absichere vorne
und hinten
sind dir natürlich viel frieden
[Musik]
für
letzteres und sprung bei weismain
geschnitzt wie so
zum verhindere das bricht in c dur in
[Musik]
münster familie wurde kurzerhand selbst
das zepter an die anatomie haye aber
jede art ich sehe aber doch anders und
hund dazu dass es schwierig ist sich
konzentrieren
ihnen ist zu nicht geschlagen werden vom
mit einer sechsmonatigen
verbuchte 11 grad
[Musik]
ich hab
ja ja wir
[Gelächter]
haben es schlimmer vorgestellt
florence kommt die vier minute wieder
anziehen
[Musik]
in der spitalsbetten hat alex moore
geschicht
ihrem recht früh am morgen aber bis zu
einer haupt stunden stunden vorher und
obelix mission truck sport
[Musik]
zerschlug ist eine hauptstadt zu meiner
patientinnen gewissen ehrgeiz und bleibt
das neue sie den unterlagen stellt der
direktkontakt zu deiner lebendige wasser
ist mir sehr wichtig dass alle mit
ausnahme
des
jahres direkt zu ihnen und sie haben
und auch und der erste patient oft
notfallstation das bis über braucht wort
ich zwei hauptmann ad hoc sie es hätte
bromacker und sich zur ruhe ohne
dramatik wie heißt er schluckt und ein
offener bruch kam ich mache sich berufs
der bundes so hat sich eine klappe ein
doppelter kieferbruch muss man sofort
operieren studentin hat mit dem halter
vor dem physik rät aber die exits leider
anders
nicht im kostüm seiten vor der operation
ist in dem dorf zhaxi
also hat er entschied dass der ums tor
das man nicht persönlich einfach mega
shark kunde will ist herzlich zum
schleifer
aber
alex ross mit glaube
jeder hat andere sicht aber schon mehr
wert ist nicht gang sondern klinik mit
chancen auf heilung
alex wird das geräte- und hatte nie den
trend anhalte sage es sich trotz
verzichten
aber wer zahlt and operation es braucht
wohl bereit sind ihr die zeit gratis zur
verfügung stelle und vor allem braucht
zentrierung
der
[Musik]
operiert hat aber der flagge kommt
trotzdem schmerzen
und ohligs das gemacht der besitzer muss
160 lehrer unterschrieben und werde
nicht notfall der raphael schmidt
simkarten aris vom walde ruder herum er
hat sich trotz vor elf jahren
tierschutzverein adoptiert ob es
bestimmte
business
sitze nicht einfach so macht das hat
mich auch gewundert aber jetzt einfach
ruft putzt er ja nicht gewusst dass das
problem ist
wir haben so bin ich sauge daheim
gesehen oder dass der zug wirklich
heftig also seid sehr schmerzhaft ist
mit einer zu krieger am ganzen körper
und geist
muntaris
tätigkeiten
der
vch präzisiert
denn so beweglich gemacht und pedalen
und strampler wo es sieht aus wie
talenten im kreis bewegt unterricht
mächtig also wenn man mit dem red der
reagierte nicht es rund großer
monitor in rotterdam und leiter ronny
dem moment will sich die aufbauhilfe
befürchtet alex sind schwere hirnschäden
wahrscheinlichen hirntumore
alex wo du sie finde was ihm bisher nie
genau abläuft der opfer lebte lie mit
sieneke zwei kurze vorstellung dass er
es noch elf jahre sind die verlierer
machten große mir
super zu trauern
um ihr herr jan bendik entwickelt also
jetzt so im museo zu mir genauso
der sich schon mit olics und als sie ist
ganz vorne liegen
so gut
reagiert
trotzdem sind beunruhigt
bereits medial fall kalt
der as rom liegt der fall darum will ich
so schnell wie möglich organisieren
[Musik]
doris dezidiert damit er sich dort
bewegt
[Musik]
mit dem apparat trend radiologe es hier
liefert dreidimensionale untersuchen
[Musik]
und tatsächlich sieht man auf dem
bildschirm in kleine flache wurde erst
gar nicht kommt
der natürlich verantwortlich sie der
fall wird dem 80 liegt ihnen vom
neurologen flottem raffael vor der
tumor-operation
die operation machen oder etwas dazu
gefragt
machen wir das
so eine heikle operation in dem lee nach
otze hier muss man gut vorbereitet die
operation an sich ist glaube ich mir
einfach in unseren köpfen auch groß weil
es halt dann geht am gehirn zu operieren
und das ist auch für besitzer oftmals
und ja auch jedes ist etwas spezielles
das macht man nicht jeden tag man muss
auch ihre vorbereitet sein für die
komplikationen dann ist es auch von
daran ist dass die seite auf mal seiner
größe es auch er
der alles runter stimmt denn sie station
wo alex
und da ist gar keine abgespielt
jetzt wurden eine thrombose im herrlich
sie suchte er ist ruft peter olics
rekord erwartet geduldet auf seine
operation
[Musik]
jede kritik fort de león zum freiburger
tierschutzverein dem heim werdet
jährlich bis zu musik und
dafür dort setzte sich die zwölf
aufstellte und genauso viele freiwillige
helfer für das didier weiteres neues die
104 stunden ost eleonore möglichst viel
von dem trainer bei amtlichen der
alexandra ist für tönt zuständigen
ältere zauberin darum kannte die
vierbeiner fachlich hört zeigte der
eleonore der neuankömmling von der buche
[Musik]
der junge pink heißt bobby
das ist ja wenn gar nicht gemacht worden
ist
das ist ja wunderbar
co-trainer heißer trend lakers in der
wacker forderung
eines symbolischen pc gutes wetter hat
probiert aus verloren
[Musik]
mal vorstellen was ist da hängt vom
endet dafür verlangen dass ich sie
hiermit liebt was ihnen da irgendwas sie
können das
ist das was ist ihre verklebt war ja
hier gut liegt jeder aber hey you see
blieb am
start fast aber seine familie seine
warum mach mit der
stange
mit viel geduld hatte alexandre das lieb
hinter wieder beruhige
mit der fairnet vergattert ist es dir
traumatisiert ich wurde mit dem ist im
umgang
als lektorin nutzbar so nicht umgekehrt
der alexandra muss zu härteren mitteln
briefe ein buntes hand durch zum der
profi besseren hebe er wird thomas besch
tiefe das handy
jetzt noch die zweite modell eee note
vorher nur grüne machen
in der sportwoche werte bin ihre neue
familie & co
grobe und hütten entwickeln
juni und darum schortens groß dass sie
eine familie die offene
es ist immer noch recht ruhig da lag ich
im tierheim zu machen weil das heißt
dass das tier wird er das jahr lang hat
geblieben und nicht von der familie code
modernes
projektkosten statistisch guitar rock
historie finden das macht mich traurig
schaut schon großartig auto
familie weber nicht
[Musik]
das tut mir sehr leid für die tiere
wurde großteil vor ihrer sie
das liebe tier
im tierheim schaffen
[Musik]
henzler
eleonor nimmt das nagetier tvo operiert
werden muss mit die praxis der alexander
kümmert sich um sie in die heiminsassen
und schenkt den trick und zuneigung 5
zuvor hatte schon adoptiert wenn dem
heim schafft es immer wieder das tier
wurde das heißt sie nimmt es spontan zu
verlieren ist ein spezialfall ist apple
wo man sicheren jetzt kann platzieren
und der kunde erhält mit hey wunder sich
wohl fühlt der ist jetzt erfolgte vor
für mich sind
wo im tierheim startet darum nämlich die
alte und mit will ich nicht möchte dass
sie die letzten tag verbringen ich hab's
nicht mit mir vereinbaren
wenn sie allein
mit dem moment
die für fische so dass man abschalten
wenn man herunter aber immer mit ihr
schafft das war schon möglich man denke
sich ganz offen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
im dir spital bern ist hochbetrieb
da nix kringelt sich um neue tritt
wird der ares inox braucht
der körper hat epilepsie und wird andere
schwierige hirn operation unterzogen
[Musik]
er nicht wir vorher nicht doch sehr
invasive geschichte es geht nur wenn die
spezialistinnen wo das technisch neu
unsere operation
aus uhr verschwindet im sterilen op war
jetzt bleibt nur noch in kleine platz
hut fleck
[Musik]
mit dem bohrer machte professor dr
dieses loch im schädel
regel kann verheerende folgen
die zimmer komplikationen blutigem
hempel burgfest geht es war die tablette
trotz vorsichtsmaßnahmen
loch hin schaden wird jetzt millimeter
um millimeter vergrößert bis der
neurochirurg die winzige werks messe
findet wohngruppen emmerick sieht
[Musik]
de showbiz
es ist tumor der musik ganz vorsichtig
no werden ohne dass hierbei beschädigt
wird
das hat auch so dp zb norris ausgelöst
zum sowie in der app support oder
bösartige tumor ist weg ins labor
geschickt
die ganze operation hat knappe stunde
war es ist noch nie verschlafe aber er
hat überlebt jetzt muss er rund um die
uhr überwacht werden wils risiko für
blutige immer noch sehr frisch wenn
alles gut kommentierte
baldwin als normales level 4
weniger als vom mensch was
körperfunktionen
und logisch denken leistung rechnerisch
als die von petra zb als normales leben
führen wenn sich aktualität benutzer
alle spieler und trainer
für uns immer folgeschaden von europa
der harz weniger der ares kundus
intensivstation von kirsch beton
inzwischen wurde der operation thing
geschlossen und personal gottheit
alex ist wieder been busy mit dem
brocken rief
[Musik]
das bringt das frank steckte böse zum
chirurg muss ich heute morgen bereit
erklärt hat zu operieren
[Musik]
ok wenn wir die raubtiere sich ab
geworden sie brauchen und goliath
abwarten dass es so wird ob er jemanden
der dirigent erwartet
aus
ganz ruhig ganz ruhig
ein mehrfacher bruch in der schleimhaut
zu schmerzen das operieren ist einfach
man muss zu stabilisieren und am
richtigen ort zusammen damit hebt und
unbedingt der richtige position
stabilisieren
[Musik]
drei
starts lilith offene provisorische
operation tisch dafür wird sie vor der
vorderhand vereinfachte besten operiert
[Musik]
super
er ist die firma
mitmachen ist
mit dem heute lebe sie zur adoption
schlecht geht hallo
das ist
doch das blatt
speziell die szenerie box
und alex kann endlich nach dass
bei der präsentation darum macht man
weniger als andere zum praktisch
zwischen 15 und 20 schafe und am
wochende abruf verfügbar sie und nicht
schlafen
und ich weiß dass sie das nicht ist es
anfangs im lager so gemacht das geht
nicht aber im moment nehme ich mit ihr
besetzt und sagen das ist mir ganz
wichtig
und wie man als band oder jahr
[Musik]
wir sind wieder in fahrbahnen im kanton
fribourg den cowboys sebastian am morgen
vor dem schaffe sagte zé es trotz bis in
zb
mit hatte eine branche
aber nicht speziell und wurde der stahl
hobby der honey das credo an bord einen
tag länger
mit der bestand vergrößern florence muss
gleich verbieten zum der mutter hält
prozent ausstoßen so streng roger eine
infektion büro
roger hat dich lieb problem mit dem lied
und gott geben auf fremde los
florence der vier discs
der sebastian hatte ganze spezielle
methode zum system und
ist allen aufgaben die noch ins nach der
hass krieg publica tipps für die cloud
und er ist selber ganz allein ich zum
märchen der luft das ist das neue
mietrecht
[Musik]
bis jetzt kurz bevor
[Applaus]
[Musik]
bereitet sie weiß ja dass das tier schon
heftig reagieren hast du noch eine
veränderung des sebastian band florence
diese york ein bluescreen bewegung
gemacht
junge hat sich versteckt die orks bond
mutter co jeden moment aus löhne sind
sehr vorsichtig
wenn ich mit der hand
hier drin hätten die zu viel platz
zum glücklichsten sitzung des großes
hobby
hätten krebsklinik das ist die große
chance für
mittag probiert aber es
ist
schon komisch vor dass das individuelle
suche bei der mutter zeit schwach ist
aber ich habe mich auf ihre instinkte
verlor
jedoch in flaschen aber der westen auch
ja es geht wenn ihr liebe geht es gut
acht ja die letzten reste von der
plazenta sind bist du
fit wird ist es ganz ruhig aber es geht
moment wo es nachts und dann rastet aus
und es erschien als
florence rand hinteren baum und die
sebastian probiert trotz beruhige
sei lasse
florence hat glück kommt es hätte ich
eine schlimme qsc bis er begreift
viel schneller unterwegs es reagiert
sofort so heftig auf den fluchtinstinkt
ich muss breite ausgänge ruhe trotz
klarer familie während sich roger
langsam beruhigt und das wort florence
rawlings
auf alles gefasst
festgestellt dass es im markt
das heißt das konkret warum so schwach
ist kann damit zusammenhängen dass es
wird tierisch differenziert
hinzu
kommen
es ist richtig schlapp
ich glaube du musst ihm der schöpfer
gerne miterleben und vitamin für springt
also ich nicht mehr wusste wenig
trunkenheit
passiert
der sebastianus und kate zu untersuchen
vor lauter freude vergisst dass man auch
eine cd 11
[Musik]
er probiert noch
widerrufen los
jetzt wirklich dass meine mutter machte
aus kaputt
florence geht dem haupt schnell sie nie
vitaminspritze
blieb cholera sie konnte gerade
hallo es war ja doch laufe sehr gut aber
das
rodeo ist überstanden dass sebastian
glücklich wie sie eine tier fühlt sich
der westen am
[Musik]
im berner tierspital 40 dollar bevor
noch mehr schützling alles ohne schlimme
nacht hinter sich hat
[Musik]
deren operation ist gut gegangen und der
tumor oro sac no hat ist zum glück
gutartig
schriftlich
da legst du trocadéro stoff box jetzt
muss man vor allem das verhalten ob sie
ihre kooperation im hier nie
irgendwelche schatten hinterland hätte
es gut aus in persönlichkeit hat sich
nicht verändert
denner freitag im spital
ist alles von der alex verhätschelt
wurde
besser konnte
medizin louis blues manager wo verstehe
und respektiere was mir für die
regierung machen sie bestätigen
durch dritte
nicht nötig
ich glaube reiten wiedererkennt wollen
gestreichelt der hat aber die chance ihn
als extremistisch gebraucht um zu
schützen
ich mir
hier geht der winter endlich der
normalerweise schlafen sofa und jetzt
muss er halt
ganz ehrlich das ist die gute sache
jetzt muss ich
jetzt einfach 5 aus
[Musik]
er leitet mit raffaels in q3 und hoffen
in epilepsy vw t1
bis sie hat alex frei schlägt
nummer vier tragisches herzoperation und
es ist schon super 2
du bist so eine art die donau
das restliche teil der station
[Musik]
pflegepersonal hätte das bisschen heikel
das los stefaniak rolle wo das verletzte
bisher auf ihr steht auf der
notfallstation
unter der woche
und am wochenende miss mister sinn es
wird den film schweiz fahrer
ohne freenet bereits katze das wird das
auf jeden fall leisten
ausser davos verloren hat wird plötzlich
vor seiner operation mit mitspieler alex
freut sich über das happy end
[Musik]
auf der notfallstation eine ganz feine
schmidt ganz schlimme verletzungen oder
krankheiten es geht aber immer die eine
klinik geschichte kultur und wein
motiviert mitzumachen
dank der alexa murli und des tv nidda
hat das rätsel aber hose
übrigens es heißt orion
[Musik]
drei manager
aris und raphael in schäfers am 8
[Musik]
schon am ersten tag ich hätte werfen und
springen
abgeschafft normale wie sich dies
einfach verdienen und wo nicht
die
gewerbeschau betonen
us-wirtschaft es wird darüber laufen
und habt
so
rafael ist überglücklich das widget
drittes in honig sind
[Musik]
du bist
wieder genau gleich wie vorher die ganze
welt wartet
auf dem sofa sitzen und zu mir
[Musik]
alles ist wieder ganz die high und
epilepsie erfahren hatte auch keine mega
[Musik]
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
die sendung tierarzt den 24 7 wurde
ihnen präsentiert von pro plan rief
klier mit der kraft katzen allergene zu
reduzieren